中大胆周报
因为实在太踊跃了
谢谢
谢谢观众朋友的支持
今天来住这个盘的部分
我总觉得今天轻松多了
不晓得是不是因为中秋节廉价呢
还是因为最近的新书还算卖得不错
是 恭喜
但另外一个也一个重要因素就是
我们这个9月已经快度过了
说真的应该很多的股民会觉得
这段时间包括7、8、9月的时间
坦白讲上不上又下不下
然后一直纠结在这里
这个快过了
那原则上来讲
我个人认为说
等这个时间到了
过完之后
我们接下来就开始更积极了
但原则上因为毕竟还有
将近有10天左右
还是要按照tempo
如果有大涨的时候
我个人还是认为先卖
毕竟这个时间点
9月份后半段隔月
还有一些不确定性因素
我们现在看一下
这个部分的一个情况
就是市场上有太多不确定性
所以最近你会发现
资金逐渐在退潮当中
尤其我在电视节目当中
我提到过
现在的周量已经创下近期的一个新低调
那下礼拜又有那么多的
包括川普跟习近平
这两个领导者的碰面
坦白讲如果不是他们两个人碰面
坦白讲这个盘大概应该就是可以底定
但是就是怕很不确定性
因为他们两个这边讲
坦白讲这是一个政治盘
政治的一些因素
就有时候就不是我们这种可以能够猜测的出来
我们可以发现到最近的资金有在退潮当中
但是有肯定的买盘护盘
所以你会发现这个大盘它大跌的过程当中
还是会有撑像这个礼拜二礼拜三的时候
我们就可以发现到确实有人在撑
那我认为中秋节前不容易连续出现大涨
那聪明的融资上礼拜有开始出现一个少见连续出场
那你要发现大盘跌它就融资减
大盘涨就融资增
一看就再度证明一点
这个应该都叫做什么
聪明融资
很聪明的
你要发现基本上融资变动
跟大盘的指数变动
基本上是正向的部分
那9月4号以来主流股不明确
我会发现过去我所观察的投信又来了
转买0050
保守
最近如果你有看投信的进出的话
你发现投信开始又比较
把0050买的比较多
因为为什么
当你不太清楚最近的主流股
很明显的
因为你会发现虽然
礼拜五还是有一些大涨个股
但是那个也是先前大跌完之后
再出现大涨
你说真的要在这个段时间
找到有连续性性的大涨的一些类股
看起来好像也没那么明显
那既然是如此的话
他投信一般过这种长假
通常就是也不知道未来
廉價完之後是漲還是跌
所以最好的方式就是買個0050
跟著指數的變動那我覺得上升區四線已經來到43000點的步驚所以我認為說如果這樣的話接下來就是未來有大盤重挫的時候你就負責去找買點的步驟
但是我還不是那麼馬上就可以往上
過這個所謂的上面
因為畢竟禮拜一禮拜二我認為說
應該有人會陸續把它賣掉
因為投資人會覺得四天有差嗎
我跟你講四天對一些用農資的人
或用大戶的人
這個資金成本差很多
那常见的支撑我认为说大概维持在4万3万
因为外资的空单虽然礼拜五有稍微降
但明显还是有将近7万多
没有明显的下降
投信高档除观望最主要是因为低的成交量
所以我认为说这行情具有不确定性
你还是拉回到稳健区的时候
你才大量的做布局
不过这一波来讲的话
我们可以发现他也买0050做观察
我刚才提到过
所以原本上来到4万5附近
你就从40%提升到50%
那同样的如果来到4万4
假如真的有不小心那两个人讲话
讲到有让指数恐慌的话
那时候你就6成到8成
因为大家已经经历过那种政治性的因素
跟经济的成长面的部分来讲
他终究还是回到经济成长面的那条路上
所以这个部分是比较算是假设性的
假如说万有真的回到那位置
你就做6成到8成
有点上45,000多点的话
上礼拜如果有来到
那个相对低的位置
其实应该就稍微
可以稍微做一个
小量的低阶的部分
同样如果拉回到43,000的部分
可以布局到八大九成
我们上次也提到过
将拉回两到三周
那这礼拜是第一周
怎么叫拉回
因为这礼拜的高
比上礼拜的高来的低
这礼拜的低
比上礼拜的低来的低
换句话说
这个礼拜就算是
一个拉回的整理周
那下礼拜呢
我认为说还是会进行到
另外一个礼拜的时间会进行整理
所以假如说到月底的时候
下个礼拜我们在录的时候
这个盘没有太大变化的话
可能到时候我就会把指数
会再往上来做一个垫高
所以我想这个部分会跟各位表达
我一致性的想法就是
时间没到你就是不要那么冲动
那我们来看一下这礼拜最主要的
当然还是在货币政策的部分
货币政策当然各位都应该有知道
相关的这个新讯息部分
我还简单帮大家做一个
再做一个回复的部分
美国联准会这次首度升息
那也暗示这个联底会再做一个升息
那而且这次的一个联邦的整个一个
12名委员全部都同意升益
那甚至在会后声明表示说通膨人居高
今天的政策行动
因为引用他当天的讲话
将有助于会让这个两派的目标
会慢慢实现物价的稳定
换句话说
你很清楚未来可能这个美元的升息的力量
还是应该会往上走
那台湾的部分央行是连始动
但是他讲到CPI目前超过2%
预期明年会下降
还有在时间在观察
不过有相关报道是说
预期第四季会升息机力大升
我个人认为说应该就不太会了
因为选前没有升选后再升
我觉得因为到那时候
一般人要讲连关钱
有些人要借钱
有时候生利息也不太好
所以加上房子
虽然有放比较松
但是这个房贷跟这个利息还是有息息相关所以我就觉得应该就干脆如果明年2%不会过应该就顺势就干脆就一直维持下去那房市的部分就是这次
这个从这个六成
第二户的放动到七成
这个部分也助于房地产至少
可以稍微有一个机会
不要像之前那么使气沉沉
那我们先来看一下
过去升息后整个股市
它的整个变化
它還是有機會去做一個上漲的部分
從我們最近來看的整個FED6次的升息的部分
從美國跟台灣的走勢來看
S&P500升息後的6個月當中
大致上原則上平均是上漲將近4.04%
唯一下跌是在2022年那一年是因為空頭市場
升息後的一年其實上也有11.23%
那台灣的部分呢
除了1997年的時候
那時候是下跌以外
其他也是跟美股是一樣
那如果我們看升息後的六個月
是負得1.29%
升息之後的一年也有3.75%
所以看起來升完息之後
沒有說想像中那麼可怕
最主要還是在於說
當你的企業成本雖然是增加
但是你的成長力道更強的時候
其实这个就不碍于整个股市的表现
尤其现在台湾的AI这个地位
更是在全球更具有一个重要的角色
所以我想如果早期没那么危险
甚至之后我们应该的走势应该会跟美股会甚至会更好
但我还是特别强调
第三季还没到
因为不到9月30号那一天
因为数字统计就是按到9月30号
过去呢
我还去强调一下
过去第一季跟第二季涨
第三季大部分80%是下跌
那如果看起来的话
第二季收在46126点左右
换句话说如果这样的话
那么现在在47000
我就认为说你还是要把它稍微卖掉一下
那这个部分第一季大涨5个%
最多2019年0.92
那其他第三季都是跌
也就是说如果按照最好的第三季上涨
也大概落在46641
看起来目前47000
还是有压回的情况
如果把这两季
第一季跟第三季
通常涨幅也加起来是低于10%
如果算起来的话
大概如果算10%的话
那么大概会落在46343
不管用什么角度去看
都是比礼拜五的收盘来得高
所以下礼拜有廉价
那这个部分我认为说
确实还是见好就收
但是拉股的时候
你就可以去留意
为什么这块部分
我还是要这么要小心
来跟各位做一个说明
坦白讲
我通常会观察上贵
现在上贵通常是属于内支
外支通常就是进进出出
你也知道上个礼拜的
外支的进跟出变化
就是那么大
但是你会发现到
目前上贵的指数的季限是下弯的
下弯就代表什么
他随时还是会有压回到这个季线之下
那现在的位置呢
即将在过一段时间开始要扣底
季线就是我们图上所看的
450点以上的高档位置区
也就是说季线它还是会有一个向下弯的情况这个情况要带来什么样的情况大概我预计啊如果这一波这个大盘这个上跪的部分能够持续维持现在这个位置
大概就目前这个位置
390点就附近
不往下走
就是走持平的话
那么大概在10月
大概呢
上旬这个部分
差不多就会扣抵到400点位置区
那大所有的季线
就很容易会出现一个走稳或是上扬
所以我認為說這段時間還是會有一些不確定性的一些壓力的部分
那你觀察日量有沒有明顯在萎縮
看起來目前日量是沒有在萎縮
表示說這個市場上的OTC沒有看淡
只不過要消化先前的一些套籠賣壓的部分
那我認為說只要中秋節這之前都能夠守穩的話
我覺得大致上都應該算是可以準備來迎接第四季的旺季的部分
那这所谓的样子当然还是
跟我书上也会讲的有关
我上个礼拜我们提到说
我人生第一本就
出了9月9号发行
那这本书有三个重点就是
投资金句
因为我都喜欢用金句来表达
投资面的一些想法
不用用太复杂
你只要记金句
你就知道那种精神
当然里面有明确的好牌
就是名牌
里面有很多好公司
包括举个例子
像最近的京城
京城在台湾大还没有明显
在把它拉大的时候
其实京城早就已经在那个名单里面
就是这其中的一份子了
那再来就是会有升官发财
就是把我过去这二三十年
为什么的收入会增加
还有为什么能够从乡里一路升上来
我当然还是有一些些的方式
给大家做分享
如果你参考的话
我相信在五年后或十年之后
或20年之后
我不敢保证你说一定
但是应该是会有助于你
往上来做发展成长
那我也再度感谢大家的支持
因为上市第六天之后
大概就是在上个礼拜一
出版商跟我讲说
那个已经卖光了
要再印第二版了
要再版了
我也很高兴
很多的我看读者或网友提到说
有时候去订的时候
刚好没有
同样这次博客来的书订会比较多
那我想中秋节呢
除了要吃月饼看月亮
那当然如果可以的话
你就是可以把这本书卡好消化
其实我尽量用浅显易懂的方式
来跟大家做分享
所以中秋节有四天
你可以把握一些时间
然后中秋节完之后
花个三四百块
马上就把我这二三十年
一些很多的金毛都吸收过去了
很划算
好 写书真的不容易
坦白说
我一直都认为愿意出书叫做做功德
真的是这个样子
这个几百块钱的书
确实浓缩了过去二三十年
总大胆他投资上面的精华
心得甚至职场上的想法
都想跟大家做分享
可以写成书就代表这些事情
是可以一直很倦勇的传承下去
这个我们在上一集有跟大家讲
那当然我们也很期待过完中秋节之后
我们能够迎来一个快乐的第四季
所以对于我们接下来操作
有兴趣的朋友
自然也很欢迎订阅我们的VIP
我会把订阅的链接放在留言的第一栏哦
那我们就VIP见吧